- This is our day.
- [Tom Brady:] This is what we do it for
right here.
- [Travis Kelce:] Hey! No moment's
ever too big for us!
- Go, Pack, go!
- [Announcer:]
Hardman fumbles the ball.
It's recovered by Buffalo.
- Look at me. Hey, look at me.
Hey, we're good.
Just be you. You're gonna
make a play this game.
- [Fan:] Floats it up and over!
- Y'all seeing football
at its greatest right now.
- We still ain't played our best yet.
- Nope.
- Welcome
to the playoffs, baby.
- Hey, these games
ain't for everybody!
These games for the elite!
- Just give all you got!
- [Devin White:] Championship Sunday, man!
- Yes.
- Championship Sunday.
- Where else would you rather be
right now? Look at this.
- [Joe Buck:]
It just doesn't get any better
than what we're about to see.
We can't wait for this game
to unfold in front of our eyes.
We know you feel the same way.
- ♪♪♪ There once was
a football team that played ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ At Lambeau Field
in ol' Green Bay ♪♪♪
- ♪♪♪ Soon may
the Buccaneers come ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ To challenge Rodgers,
Jones and Adams ♪♪♪
- ♪♪♪ Go, you Packers, go ♪♪♪
- ♪♪♪ Go, boys, Tampa Bay, go ♪♪♪
- [Carlton Davis:] This time last year,
we was considered
the worst team in the NFL!
But look where we at now!
- [Za’Darius Smith:] You gonna watch out
for them holding calls, right?
- Snowing up in England.
Great day for some
NFC Championship Game.
Go, Pack, go!
- Let's go, Bucs!
- We know we wanna go!
We wanna go play at home
next week!
We gotta take care of today!
- If I make this, the Packers
are going to the Super Bowl.
♪♪♪
Whoo!
- [Micah Hyde:] Oohwee!
AFC Championship Game!
Let's go, let's go!
The whole world watchin'.
- [Fan:] Go Bills.
- [Jim Nantz:]
The AFC Championship Game.
The top two seeds:
the Buffalo Bills
and the Kansas City Chiefs.
- [Frank Clark:] Yeahhh!
- [Fan:] You know what time
it is, Chiefs Kingdom.
- We know what we made of.
- Here we go, Bills Mafia!
AFC Championship!
- [Josh Allen:] Yeah!
- [Cheering]
- Keep that camera on me, dawg.
All game.
- [Fan:] Let's go!
- This what I work for!
This what I work for,
right here!
- AFC Championship, man.
Back to back to back!
Stay tuned!
[Crowd cheering]
- [Announcer:]
Brady has all kinds of time.
Throws toward the end zone.
It is a caught ball!
Touchdown, Tampa Bay!
Mike Evans!
- [Fan:] Floats it up and over!
Bucs strike first!
- [Evans:] Tom threw
a perfect ball, bro.
Wow. Cuz that went right over him.
- [Lavonte David:] Playoff litty! Playoff litty!
- [Fan:]
Hit the spin "B" button.
- [Buck:]
The spin and...touchdown!
- Touchdown! Baby, let's go!
- Way to go. Nice job.
That turned into zone on that.
- Yeah.
- Way to see it.
- [Announcer:] Hardman
standing at his 11-yard line.
Drops it! Muffs it!
Bills' ball on the 3-yard line.
- Let's go, baby!
- [Fan:] Dawson Knox, Dawson Knox, Dawson Knox.
- [Nantz:] To Knox.
To the end zone.
- Whoo! Yes!
- [Nantz:] Buffalo touchdown.
- Mecole! Come on.
- Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Look at me. Hey, look at me.
Hey, we're good.
Just be you. You're gonna
make a play this game.
- [Announcer:] Hardman
on a wide receiver screen.
Into the end zone! Touchdown!
- [Announcer:] Helping us to
forget about that muffed punt.
- Hey! Hey!
That's how you handle adversity!
Let's go. We're rolling.
One at a time!
Do it again!
- Next play!
Your next play your best play!
- [Byron Leftwich:] We just gotta be ready
to attack outside, one-on-one.
- [Buck:]
Brady goes for the deep shot!
He's got a touchdown!
Scotty Miller!
- Hey!
- You already know!
You already know!
- Hey. Hey.
- Scotty Miller time, baby.
Let's go.
- Brady's masterful.
- That’s them big nuts.
- All day.
You know I got those, baby.
- Whoo!
- [Matt LaFleur:] Well, we're gonna find out
a lot about ourselves
right here.
- [Andy Reid:] This drive. This drive.
- [Kelce:] Just cuz we got that lead
don't mean we can't get more.
- [Nantz:] Here's Mahomes.
Look at—underhanded.
He throws it for the touchdown!
- [Kelce:] Ahh!
Hell yeah!
Way to trust it, baby!
- Yo, so I told y'all
Aaron Rodgers
was gonna have to
put his cape on.
- [LaFleur:] Let's go! Believe it!
- Aaron Rodgers,
put the team on your back!
- [Buck:] Slings it.
- Yeah!
- [Buck:] Touchdown, Tonyan.
- [LaFleur:] Nice job. Hell of a job, man.
- [Davante Adams:] You had to have that.
You had to. I could tell.
- [Announcer:] Blitz is on.
Throw, right side.
- [Fan:] Let's go, baby!
- [Announcer:] Touchdown!
- It ain't over yet!
Let's goooo!
- Hey, we gotta
get a stop right here.
- We should have
a field day today.
He's trying
to throw y'all a pick.
- [Announcer:]
Brady under center.
He pop flies,
and it is intercepted again!
- [Fan:] Packers starting to
feel like a team of destiny!
- [Troy Aikman:]
Tom Brady knows that his night
is far from being over.
- It took eight years
just to get back to here, dawg!
Let's finish!
- [Announcer:]
7:41 to go in the game.
- Third down and goal.
- [Fan:] Chiefs, boys.
- [Nantz:]
Lobs it up in the air to Kelce.
- [Fan:] Touchdown, Chiefs!
- [Announcer:]
The Bills' season is over.
- This is the proudest I've been
of this team in almost 30 years.
- Hey, way to ball, man.
First of many. First of many.
For sure.
- Good luck.
- For the city, I go crazy, man.
This is what I do, man!
- We goin’ again, baby!
- Back-to-back AFC champs!
Goin’ to the Super Bowl again!
- How 'bout those...
- [Together:] Chiefs!
- [Announcer:] Can the Packers
get a score here
and a two-point conversion
to get this thing tied?
With time initially.
Steps up, scrambles.
Throws late over the middle.
Incomplete.
My goodness.
Aaron could have-—[sighing]
- [LaFleur:] Oh. Kick it. Kick it.
- [Announcer:] Wow. You would’ve
liked to have seen them
get it done there.
- [LaFleur:] Hey, we got three timeouts.
- [Announcer:]
I'm a little surprised
they didn't actually go for it
on fourth down there.
- What?
- They're kicking a field goal.
- Why?
- [Aikman:] I thought
that they would go for it
on fourth down.
- [Fan:] Me too, Troy. Me too.
- You want me to illustrate
why that's so dumb or—
now or later?
- Let's go. This is it.
- [Chris Godwin:] This is the one.
- This gotta be it.
- [Aikman:] Who else would you
rather have than Tom Brady,
the greatest to ever do it?
- [Buck:] Third down and five
with 48 seconds left.
- [Fan:] Yes!
- [Buck:] Toss to Godwin.
- Yes!
- [Buck:] He's got the first
down, and this game's over.
- I waited so long for this.
- We're goin’ to the Super Bowl!
- [Evans:] Let's go!
- We comin' home!
- [Brady:] Great playing, bro.
- Good job, Tommy.
- [Brady:] You had a great season.
- Super Bowl-bound, baby!
- We made it.
History made, baby!
We in there, baby!
- Big bro, man. Love you, man.
Let's go. One more. We at home.
- I know. I know.
- We're at home!
- I really look up to you,
too, man. Man, keep your head up.
- Let’s go to the Super Bowl, baby.
- Let's go.
- [Brady:] How ‘bout it, brother?
- You've only done this
10 times.
- Well, it's a little different
this year.
- Yeah. I'd say so.
- A lil’ different.
- I got somethin’ real special
for my Green Bay Packer fans.
Hold on.
- ♪♪♪ The crew sailed up
to Lambeau Field ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ The Super Bowl's
on our own home field ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ We'd be the first one
of our kind ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ We'll take our rings
and go ♪♪♪
- Fresh out the smoker.
- [Fan:] Whoo!
- A hot "L."
- [Fan:] A fresh, hot "L."
- We goin’
to the Super Bowl, baby!